sac à dos plein à blanc sur la tête ces
jeunes de la paroisse de trappes sont
parés pour leur grand périple un voyage
à travers l'europe mais aussi un voyage
spirituel
réunis à la place d'armes de versailles
depuis 9 heures ils font partie des 2000
jeunes qui attendent leur bus direction
cracovie pour les journées mondiales de
la jeunesse
nous ça a commencé par la prière départ
de trappes à la gare ensuite c'est la
joie une joie contagieuse on va dire on
chante librement notre foi des le train
on est on est au taquet on est prêt pour
pour vivre une belle aventure
spirituelle
un rendez vous auquel il se prépare
depuis des mois les membres
cracovie 2016 géorgie le glaçon de la
vie de famille vie de la paroisse et au
centre la page la pastorale des jeunes
les autos
laplaud
le drapeau de la tension
c'est un grand moment à vivre je pense
que ça va être super riches sont au
niveau de la fois de la rencontre qu'on
peut faire
déjà au niveau du groupe on va falloir
sortir encore plus forts au niveau de
l'hospitalité des polonais aussi face à
m cette année les jeunes chrétiens parce
parviennent pour se rendre à cracovie en
pologne
du 26 au 31 juillet ils assisteront à
des messes mais aussi des conférences un
moment de réflexion sur la foi et la
religion
bah pour moi c'est une vraie expérience
d'église c'est à dire aller avec déjà
tous les jeunes du diocèse de versailles
toutes les paroisses qui se réunissent
on va tous ensemble en pèlerinage est
vraiment une expérience d'église avec
voilà de se réunir plus d'un million de
jeunes du monde entier qui vont venir
autour du pape
la rencontre avec le pape françois lui
le 28 juillet il faudra en attendant
yards et la fois pour affronter les 21
heures de bus qui les séparent de
cracovie et de leur rencontre avec le
saint père